ambassador Sunland had flown back from
Brussels and was eager to appear
agreement for the deposition had been
reached to the State Department but then
at half past midnight a voicemail was
left on sunland's lawyer's phone saying
the Trump administration would not allow
him to give evidence the failure to
produce this witness the failure to
produce these documents we consider yet
additional strong evidence of
obstruction of the constitutional
functions of Congress a co-equal branch
of government republican committee
members all backed the White House move
what we see in this impeachment is a
kangaroo court and chairmen shift is
acting like a malicious Captain Kangaroo
there was no pressure whatsoever
coincidentally or not a phrase very
similar to that used by the president an
hour earlier unfortunately he would be
testifying before a totally compromised
kangaroo court tweeted President Trump
where Republicans rights have been taken
away and true facts are not allowed out
for the public to see Republican members
of the House committees insist Democrats
have been selective in what evidence to
make public particularly of that
provided last week by US Representative
to Ukraine could folker which made clear
US diplomats had been discussing the
preconditions for a meeting between
President Trump and his Ukraine
counterpart this has to be a fair
process and when you have a press
release being drafted by our Democrat
colleagues cherry-picking text messages
when the full text of ambassador
Walker's testimony last week would have
exonerated this president let's release
it ambassador Sunderland was mentioned
repeatedly in the testimony made public
his texts and emails indicating he was
in direct communication with the White
House throughout the discussions about
Ukraine his evidence is regarded as
critical in terms of understanding the
motive behind the Trump administration's
engagement with the president of Ukraine
and the House committees are insistent
he must testify
formal subpoena has now been issued
calling on ambassador Sunland to appear
with all his documents my Khanna al
Jazeera Washington